since women have the right to choose
whether or not we can be a mother should
men be able to choose if they could be a
father equality yes what does that mean
so so okay so when i if i got pregnant
today right yeah then i get to choose to
keep it or abort it yeah the man that
got me pregnant
he doesn't get to choose whether i keep
it or abort it but if i have the baby
he's stuck on child support for 18 years
if i don't stay with him should he have
the right while i'm pregnant to say you
know what i don't want to be a dad i
just want to sign off my rights i don't
want to be liable for child support
i mean again i get it i get why the guy
would think
would maybe say to the woman i want you
to abort it i don't want a kid and then
she carries the kids and it's annoying
it's like long for him but it's still he
still
did the thing right so it's still partly
his responsibility right it's but
wouldn't you say it's her responsibility
too because she did the thing
so
it is but it's just one of those
unfortunate things in life like
it's down to the woman isn't it because
it's in her body so it's just the fact
of life that it's going to be her
decision not the guy's decision right
but shouldn't his wallet his decision
no because he did make the decision with
her to have sex yeah but she made the
decision with him to have sex so she
gets a choice so shouldn't shouldn't it
be equal where he made the decision and
she made the decision and they both get
a choice
so his choice would be to not pay any
money for that kids and not be involved
and just say you know what i if it was
up to me we'd abort it she doesn't want
to so i'm just not going to be on the
hook for child support
but wouldn't that cost them being picked
up by the state
wouldn't that cost be picked up by the
state
yeah how
as in if the guy is not going to pay
money then where's the money going to
come from for the kids well personally
if it was up if it was pearl's world i i
don't think single mothers should be
bailed out at all
no i mean you should pick that up get
married before you carry
get married before you carry hush get
married before you carry that's [ __ ]
so i got it and then plus the majority
of abortions actually aren't from low
income people it's actually from people
of higher income yeah that's people
making bad decisions then yeah
i got a good story about this
i know a woman who's who was 37 and she
was talking to a friend of mine
and she was saying you know you can just
if you want to get a kid just just get
knocked up with a random guy just you
know the one choose whatever guy and she
got knocked up she got she got locked up
the guy didn't want it and he was like i
don't want any responsibility with it
and she's like i don't care i'm having
it that's the way it is
so is that not very abusive in nature
but did he know that there was a
possibility she could get pregnant
because if she outright when you have
sex
she might be on protection if she's on
protection then
she could have liked it
yeah i'm saying that's not okay that's
not okay lying is yeah but i'm saying
i'm saying even like like she legally
could lie to him and and she's like that
yeah but this is what but i'm going back
to we are incentivized to bad behavior
is incentivized because of feminism
so like that's why why do you think that
girl was stealing drake's freaking
condom drake did everything right
you don't think that corn star that got
his kid did the same thing that stuff
was bad
she was recording the guy drake's baby
mama was a corn star
you don't think that she would do
something
so a guy could do in that case he did
everything right what more could he do
wear a condom and she could steal the
steal his his seed put it up there get
pregnant and he's on the hook for 18
years and in the u.s he gets 25 percent
of that man's income every year
by the nba as well actually 25 percent
of the revenue athletes get done yeah
they're not that's yeah
it's not fair that's different i think
baby they would never know how she got
pregnant so don't you think they should
just be able to get the same rights that
women get
i think that situation where the woman's
deceitful that's a different situation
he would never know
like if the average guy that happens to
he he's never going to know that she did
that
all he knows is that she's pregnant so
don't you think we have a moral
obligation from a or don't we don't we
have a legal person
a legal we should legally protect those
men
and give them the same right that women
get i think if it's like literally
stealing a bodily fluid to make yourself
pregnant then there should be some kind
of legal thing involved there that makes
sense okay but you don't think that men
should get the same right that women get
to choose not to be a father again it's
like
women are the ones that have to carry
the kids so that's kind of unfair in
general so i feel like some things in
life are not fair and that's one of
those things that's not fair
you have responsibility over whether you
get pregnant or not
but i'm just saying
i don't think men envy women for having
to carry a kid for nine months so that's
an inequality that's always going to be
present just like maybe this situation
for my opinion but you you you're a
woman and you know that this thing can
happen to you right so you consciously
you make the decision to sleep with the
guy and you know that okay for lack of a
better use you are at a disadvantage
because if anything happens you're gonna
have to carry it so yeah you do it
anyways you get pregnant and then why
why do i have to have to so far
and plus it's a i think it's 100 the
girl's fault if she gets pregnant it's
100 the girl's fault because you have
the opportunity to get an iud you can
get on birth control you can make the
men that sleep with you wear a condom
because as long as there's no essay you
you get to pick who gets to sleep with
you
on top of that you can do adoption on
top of that you can get an abortion so
we have choice choice choice choice
choice men only have one choice then
they can even do that and the girl can
still steal it and have the same outcome
yeah i mentioned the stealing there
should be something legal involved but
if it's like you have a sexual sex and
then like the condom breaks for example
like it's not anyone's fault and then
she gets pregnant then you still got the
morning after pill now i forgot you're
right morning after pill or maybe okay
maybe not split so maybe they just get
she gets pregnant like randomly and
doesn't like no other random they were
trying
is it random i just slipped
so she made a choice to to sleep with
someone she shouldn't have slept with
and then she made a choice not to go on
birth control and then she made a choice
not to take the morning after pill
and then she made a choice not to get an
abortion
and then she carries the kid and makes a
choice not to give it up for adoption
sounds like a lot of choices and the man
can't get can't get one
i feel like again it's just one of those
things that there isn't a perfect
solution to it and in this case bring
about male birth control come on i think
i think the perfect solution is to let
men get a financial abortion
that's your opinion i think i disagree
with that okay what do you guys think
i mean pro-life pro-choice no i'm not
really like try corn or anything like
that so
uh
yeah
yeah this is this this is a tough one
i'm kind of like people should have
there should be more rights for men if
they want to oblige out of uh
having a kid and i i do believe that
it's the responsibility of the woman to
who's having that kid you have so many
different choices to be able to do that
and i think a guy should be able to
financially what what's the word
financially about is that what yeah
financially abort if if you if he wants
to
and that being said uh
i think guys should encourage men to
take responsibility and kind of raise
that kid
but
if they don't want it they don't want to
and if they should have that right to be
able to because that's equality right is
it
i mean i think men should take care of
the kids they have like
absolutely but i don't think they should
be on the hook i don't think she should
get a lifestyle out of it you can get a
job just like you can what do you what
are you you can't work
just because you had a child
and employees are much more facilitating
like sometimes i think girls are just
lazy like they don't want to get a job
no i'm serious what is i mean i get it
you have to carry the kid but after that
you get like getting something to get
money yeah but like you know when people
give birth they lose a lot of like
vitality and energy right
if someone says i've just given birth to
like a kid this kid weighed like three
did you not hear what i said i said six
months she can you know chill okay okay
and then go get a job it's not like
you're making excuses but he's i don't
know wait why are we making excuses for
that pregnancy looks looks very
challenging so i can understand it
if someone doesn't come out of that
as as sprightly and you know
with the same vitality the same body
they had when they were you know 21
years old yeah but i just i don't think
she's entitled to his money no you're
not entitled to have it like him pay for
your lifestyle yeah so my my view on
this is very like
straightforward right
pro-choice but that has to come with the
financial
abortion right so everyone has maximum
freedom right you can you can choose to
have a kid you can choose not to have a
kid i can choose to support a kid i can
choose not to support a kid i think
that's the only rational way of
approaching this
you know the other way would if you
force people to you know not
how they use their bodies then you have
to go down a really kind of dodgy slope
of
when when's too far
you know how much can i get you to do
with your body
um so yeah i would once too far when
you're infringing on someone else's body
which is the kid